she didn't want me to do it but I did it
anyway and reply to his question are you
ready to see the funny side yet his
stepmom Emma Hopkins will get her age in
a second said not really no I [__]
had those ashes for 12 years the
Articles wait he died 12 years ago
stick around
Tony's who want to thank our sponsor
prize picks prize picks is the most fun
that I've had winning up to 25 times my
money this football season you just
select two or more players pick more or
less on their projected stats and place
your entry what you do is you go to
prize picks.com slash DPT use the code
DPT for a first deposit match up to a
hundred dollars that's prizepix.com TPT
use the code TPT for a first deposit
match up to 100 promo codes all lower
case prize picks daily fantasy sports
made made easy welcome to another
episode of dumb people Town population
years population O'Brien Mike O'Brien
welcome to the show what's up guys so
happy to have you I'm so excited to do
it yeah I mean like you talk about dumb
people kind of skirting around having me
for years we've been wanting it for
years that's true I kept requesting
people
Dan kept requesting we said no it needs
to create more quality shows on TV
you were so busy you're like I'm doing
AP Bio I'm doing this and that you were
yeah busy being successful and we
couldn't get to you and now we got you
yeah and a pandemic and a strike freed
me up a little bit yeah all of us
we have many many connections Second
City with Daniel yeah Ann Arbor some of
my favorite stuff on SNL of course yes
oh my God hilarious we're fans fans
first but connections next and now
you're here with us and we get to just
break down dumb Behavior I got a dumb
story great I think we jump right into
it let's Jump Right In and then we'll
find out what you got going on which is
an amazing podcast with our buddy uh
Brad Morris we'll talk about that later
buddy first story sent in by uh by I
almost did her uh Twitter handle Carlene
McDermott she be Carlene thank you
Marlene the way to do it is you just uh
tweet at Daniel Van Kirk at scar
Brothers hashtag dumb people town that
lets us know when you found the story
and this one was sent in by uh Carly
McDermott okay you ready here's the
headline son loses dad's ashes in Tesco
bag for life after several hour booze
filled Bender
I love that they shaded him a little bit
okay just you know you've lost these for
life for life right yeah they're great
how do we know that he's not gonna I
know that's not what your dad wanted you
to do what's a Tesco bag yeah what is
that Tesco's like a uh like a
supermarket in it's like a Dwayne Reed
or early yeah or like uh where should I
put Dad's throw him in a Tesco bag it's
like a mire yeah it's like a mire I mean
it's more like eagles I really can't
find out but were they loose in there
yeah just straight up lift okay so it's
like the jewels the story comes to us
from the mirror in the UK all right a
shame-faced sun I mean yeah there's a
lot of op-ed in the same space
Sun opened for They Might Be Giants and
I didn't feel that it was a good pairing
but I'm not sure the sun shuts down like
a 10 000 maniac song from that first
album
full-bodied
is perfect for any Irish band because
you don't talk about it you're just
shame face yeah let me have two blue
moons and a shame-faced sun yeah it also
sounds like a line from bans season
finish here in it but I don't like any
shameful he's shame-faced I the regret
hipped daughter anyway all right shame
face on his appealed for help in finding
his dad's ashes that's bad too when
you're like hey has anybody seen a
Tesco's bag filled with oh that's better
because I thought he spilled them and he
was and I'm like you think you're gonna
be lost I'm not an idiot I tied the top
the writers already decide they're gone
forever right what's he bothering right
the writers not even like there's no
hope there's no hope for this writer
it's like a parent you're gonna go out
and look for your bike don't bother it's
gone are you gonna go look well I don't
know do you want me to look or not yeah
don't bother uh and finding his dad's
ashes which he lost in a Tesco bag for
life again but for life I think this
writer is related to the dad yeah for
life this is written by his uncle
are you happy about that you happy after
quote so this is is where you're like
this guy's dumb after quote one last
trip to the beach turned into a how many
hour pub crawl I feel like you just read
the back of a VHS after one last trip to
the beach turned into a Michael found
out what a real pub crawl was all about
and I'll I'll give him a holiday weekend
it burns I'll give it with my answer
after one last trip to the beach turned
into a nine hour popcorn okay what do
you think after what you got to do it
with that voice okay
[__]
to the beach
uh it turned into a 18-hour post wow it
can happen that's a serious
yeah yeah it can't be like two after one
last trip to the beach turned into a
14-hour pub crop get your answers in
town is because after one last trip to
the beach one of you is exactly right oh
so now we get to play do you think yeah
you're right yeah
nine or 14. I'm staying with nine I'm
going 14. okay you can stay where you're
staying before okay after one last trip
to the beach turned into a nine hours
oh that feels good yeah think of college
just ballpark what is the longest
drinking day you've ever done but I'll
give you time Patrick it's mine too it's
Chicago St Patrick's day starting at 6
a.m South Side I ended I ended up at one
point I was drinking I think off
diversity I'm all back on I was drinking
at a Chipotle because they served
Margaritas yeah stop it and I think I
went and to I got to a point we were in
a place called Triton tap on Lincoln and
I I know this is a lie guys don't get
wrong it's just dumb Midwestern I I
looked at Bradford and Corey and I said
I I think I've drunk myself sober I
don't I don't feel anything anymore I'm
just going home you could be drunk too
yeah we used to kind of drink for the
full 24 hours of uh we would do improv
for 24 hours it was for charity yeah
I've had some long but I didn't start
until late yeah I mean it's yeah how
much are you drinking at each place is
kind of the thing too I St Patty's Day
you've done on and off for 24 hours yeah
like on and off like all right I'll have
another one little Bailey's in the
coffee at some point yeah exactly yeah I
think we've done St Patty's Day 12 hours
I did a nine to six one time that had
nine hours I mean that's that's a long
time all right stand blade that's his
name no plan blade Stan blade blade all
right Stan blade
Stan blade planned to make a Tick-Tock
video of himself visiting pleasure rides
at South End Essex with Dad Steven
jewett's ashes as a final farewell but
instead visited the Dodgers on South End
Pier with his Dad we want to let's do
this at the end we'll get his age at the
end uh and bumped into a group of old
Pals and ended up on a Pokemon these are
his dad's though his spouse his Pals and
ended up in a pub crawl what are you
doing I'm about to scatter my eye oh
[__] that come on it's not important
what are your next nine hours now I
noticed I notice his dad's name isn't
blade yeah
that's his I mean
which is why he went to go do the rides
because that's what his dad did with him
during like his his visitation time
right that was the weekends with the
death Dan his mother his most convincing
friends like let me ask you something he
gonna be dead in nine hours you can come
by the way they're British and Jay's
making them you're still gonna be dead
nine hours
he liked to do two things beat the [__]
out of you and drink something
we're doing it for him he's still gonna
be ashes in nine hours because we've all
had times on the road where you've
either gone to a bar or gone to even
[__] breakfast with your luggage with
one bag and it is the most oh [__] I
forgot my luggage like it's the most uh
can I can you guys keep this here this
dude's doing this with a bag of Ashes a
Tesco's bag of ashes and getting more
and more impaired and more drunk yeah
right it's not just time it's reduction
of facilities
when they saw him you know they were
like blader yeah later dude
shame face might just be flush from
being drunk yeah he's just
sometime during the drink Stan misplaced
the shopping bag containing a wooden
casket which held the ashes of his dad
wait so we're out of the bag it's so no
it was in a wood basket from the
beginning they had us believing it was
just a loose back this is even crazier I
know wooden cabinets and you know he's
drinking for free you're doing a pub pub
crawl and you have I got my dad in here
you're not getting charged wait but
putting ashes in a casket is kind of a
funny like thing that you've like I will
not be buried I will not be bare where
should we put these ashes in a mini
casket and then lower into a tiny hole
this by the way it is a plot of
downsizing right it is weird because big
casket you just go somebody died small
casket you're like oh my God a child but
can I just say then it starts being
funny right this is almost like a family
guy because if you go far enough you're
like this is hilarious and I think the
tiny the dad who's the biggest should be
in the smallest casket tiny casket being
loaded yeah all right I was mad at Elton
Johnson
lower me down
she held that tiny casket closer he only
discovered his blender after finally
arriving home just after midnight on
Saturday March 18th after having drunk
how many how many tins of Stella and how
many pints of lager tins of Stella I
don't know what that is
and how many pints of lager according to
who him yeah I mean that might be a
double narrator might not be relying it
started at 3 P.M he left after the
luncheon yeah I'd like that he only had
two types of beer and that the writer
separate just say how many beers right
just how many beer but one two pints
tins or pints tins might be big might be
the ginormous Fosters yeah like a little
mini keg of whatever it is yeah or at
least maybe it means like that like a 16
ouncer yeah maybe which is a pint as
well
um how many tins of Stella how many
pints of lager can just give you the
total number yeah I'm gonna go but I
want you to break it up too okay fine
I'll I'm I'm gonna go three and seven
three and seven might go uh nine tens
and and one Stella he didn't like that
he didn't like he went back to the ten
two and eight tens didn't like it went
back to the dead I also didn't drink
them all I put it a little bit out for
myself I drink them all but I don't know
where is go ahead dude this guy's drunk
I'm gonna say eight and nine hours yeah
ten and ten ten and ten all right get
your answers in town he's ten because
this this blade stand blade stand blade
six tins of Stella and five pints of
life in a couple of pubs he confessed to
his irate stepmom
Emma Hopkins who had previously told him
he could not take the ashes out of the
home don't take the ass she's like do
not take this up you're gonna run into
more stupid friends what's gonna happen
I've got him in a shopping bag what's
the worst we think I'm gonna hurt him
he's dead also you haven't heard any of
us at this point you're not listening to
your stepmom yeah you're not my real mom
oh I'd go years back but you really got
nothing that's keeping this is just a
woman in your house right who got who
got all your dad's stuff right musician
stand that's again
that's where the [__] blade is the
electric guitar yeah right it's solo
prog rock I came home and all
instrumental no one wants to hear that
it's like weather report
and my stepmom asks where's your dad uh
dead I don't even say she was not
pleasing me at all and I do not blame
her that's good all right Fair he added
my dad was really funny bloke anyway
would have absolutely loved the idea of
me riding a roller coaster with his
ashes at his side so he's now riding
roller coasters yeah no because he never
made it there originally yeah he had a
good sense of humor so I just wanted to
do something to pay tribute uh to that
as I haven't visited my hometown in a
while so now this is just about him
going doing [__] in his hometown yeah he
comes home
the idea was to take him to the beach go
on all the bumper cars get an ice cream
you know all the stereotypical things
you do could you imagine the bumper cars
put your dad in a tiny casket you put
your kid in the bumper car and you're
like hit the guy with the casket
and then it's like a plume of smoke in
your kid's face LeBron getting ready to
go on the court Well your dad's in his
final resting place where's that the
floor of the bathroom of the Thirsty
Crow or you just see the plume and
you're like the [__] kind of gender
reveal is that they're having a great
kid
we don't know all right we're gonna let
our kid be what they want but we're
still then why'd he even do the gender
reveal we're not defining it so you're
supposed to be eating that was the ideal
version too was he rides bumper cars
with bashes right
but I ended up bumping into friends and
getting drunk along the seafront after
uh releases uh realized his dad was
missing Stan went straight back to scour
every Pub we've been with the friends
but no one had seen his dad all right if
you see a bag this is a movie this is
like a heroin finding finding my dad's
ashes this is like a drunken adult
Finding Nemo he last saw the wooden
casket holding his dad's ashes near
Adventure Island on the seafront he then
made a Tick-Tock appeal for information
about where about the ashes in the video
uh say he made the same title saying
missing person Stan explained that he
was visiting his hometown from Leicester
where he now lives to see family and
friends when he came with the idea still
slurring in the video no I mean come on
we open on him coming home
she says where's Dad he goes leave me
alone oh [__] then the super fast hyper
rewind and then the movie starts with
him heading to the beach still slurring
in the video of the ball crawl I
convinced my stepmom to do a tick tock I
thought it would be funny you don't
there's nothing wrong so she's in the
beginning reluctantly yeah put him in to
dodge him cars put him in the big wheel
give him a kiss me quick hat and stick
of rocks and stuff what do you think it
keeps me quick at it I don't know I felt
like you were reading weird Shakespeare
Double Double Toil in trouble can you
show me a kiss me quick at is a condom I
would believe yes what is it kiss me
quick I think it's literally what it is
oh oh maybe yeah and a stick of rock and
stuff I don't know what a stick of
Rocket that's crack cocaine at this
point I think he's a witch I have no
idea
she didn't want me to do it but I did it
anyway and reply to his question are you
ready to see the funny side yet his
stepmom Emma Hopkins will get her age in
a second said not really no I [__]
had those ashes for 12 years the
Articles wait you died 12 years ago
this kid is now getting around to this
he's now doing the bumper cars that
would have been the greatest guess ever
random not to shame face you but you
saying how recently had the dad I was
doing ages none of us herself
they did they started out they started
these are her quotes yeah start again
with her he she he says to her are you
ready to see the funny side and then she
says no not really no I [__] had
those asses for 12 years I
told you not to take them to the scene
all you want to do is do things on Tick
Tock
but also when she's mad later on nine
hours later I'm going you said you've
sick of having these [__] asses I
think I gave you what you really hoped
for wait wait she's using this Ash's
thing as a referendum of how much he's
on Tick Tock all you do is get on Tick
Tock let's talk about China all right
Stan's dad Steven Jewett died in 2011 at
age we'll find out from complications
from alcohol abuse I wonder if it got
fast enough he disappeared doing what he
loved too many tins this is my favorite
thing if his ashes aren't found soon
Stan says he'll report him missing hey
you can't do that can you do that he's
been missing for 12 years
and that's just dead he's moving from
your life a lot longer I think when did
you last see him alive 13 years ago
2011. yeah all right musicians and
Comics you could just ask him who left
here so here bring me one more tin okay
so there's five dreams I mean
um the fact that we had to lose in you
yeah the fact haven't made a Dust in the
Wind reference at this point the movie's
called dad's in the wind yeah it's in
the wind it's very Dude Where's My Car
yes dude where's my dad
they drank too much and lost their car I
believe yeah The Hangover just ripped
that off when we blew skied in the room
we'll figure this out okay hold on yeah
so we got to figure out how old okay so
how old let's start with him Sun how old
is the son who lost the okay he's having
done for 12 years yep
come on he's
I had him he's still in the 20s until I
until then he's still dealing with the
stepmom and he's still drunk enough to
go out and be an idiot I'm gonna go
33 years old Mike what do you think
Jesus I was feeling something like that
I'll go 30. 30. Jay what do you think
27. all right get your answers in town
he's young because this man Stan blade
musician shame-faced 39 years old oh my
God
how old was the dad when he died in 2011
Stan Jewish it was 12 years ago I can't
believe blade lives with his stepmom 12
years after that music careers
he came he lives in Leicester and he's
coming back he just does his tick tocks
he's staying right exactly right right
that's just a place to do his content
I'm gonna say that he was 51. 51 when he
died what do you think so 63 now because
he's a missing person now right uh I'll
say it takes a little while I assume to
drink yourself to death I'll go
um
55 what do you think
I think he's 58. he would be 70 now
yeah but I mean he was 58 in in 20 in
okay on 2011. I said 51. in 51 55 58 get
your answers in townies because Mr
Jewett when he died was 60 years old
now too young guys don't do it don't
drink yourself for fun now tell me how
old Emma Hopkins the Stepmom is now and
then he's been gone 12 years he was 60.
how old is she now
60 okay what do you think 67 I think she
was 48 26.
I think she was younger 13 years younger
than him 26 years saying she was 18 when
he was dating her at 60. no that
wouldn't even yeah he'd be four she'd be
14 14 but it's England okay fine there
you go
Emma Hopkins is
49 years old
60 to 37 she's a stepmom so she's number
two yeah four four or four yeah we don't
even know that but that's what it is and
I just thought that was a hilarious Lord
right
he's older than well he walked no no I
just messed it all up Dan you got Story
number two oh when you come back we're
gonna find out about the podcast that uh
Mike is doing yeah our plugs in the
podcast Mike's doing with our buddy uh
Brad it's so much fun I love it we'll be
right back dumb people Town Mike O'Brien
we'll see in a minute
hey guys welcome back to the show Mike
O'Brien is with us we're so happy we're
going to find out about and talk about
his podcast and everybody just say one
thing they love about Brad Morris who is
his co-host we'll do that in a second
first let's tell them what we have going
on Jay yeah I'm not sure when this is
dropping but we end October yeah so
early November we've got uh on November
6th we're doing another Target at Largo
and I believe Kumail is going to be on
that show and a few other wonderful
folks uh so that's really fun that's
what we tag people's jokes and show that
comedy is a community uh really
collaborative and fun and then we're
going to be uh at the Blue Room in
Springfield Missouri uh on the 9th and
10th and 11th and then on the 12th we'll
be in New York at the New York Comedy
Festival doing our two-man show which we
did out here at Dynasty typewriter which
we really love and hopefully I loved it
figuring out a way to maybe do a run of
that show maybe in New York like a
lengthy hopefully if we get asked to do
a moon tower again you guys will do it
there too I hope it's such a great space
for it they've done stuff like that
before that would be really we would
love it so that and then we're going to
be in Cleveland uh December 1st and 2nd
and a bunch of other dates Portland
Cleveland Portland Seattle uh back to
Denver at Comedy Works at the end of
January beginning of February Mark
released Comedy Castle at the beginning
end of February beginning of March uh
and then of uh what are we doing oh uh
back to uh we haven't even mentioned
this we're back at the beginning of
April in uh Minneapolis at the great
Acme Comedy Company and then moon tower
and then maybe Alaska with Gary Goldman
in uh May so good stuff happening all
around superscars.com to find out for
that to join our patreon and join this
patreon which is so much fun so much fun
and I think it happened it's only five
bucks a month it's so much fun all right
Mike let's talk about the podcast please
and we all love Brad Morris one of the
great improvisers and best character
people his drill down in the specifics
of a character is maybe one of the best
so it's so it's so Clive Owen like it's
just small moves that have huge huge
impacts truthful and funny he's one of
the reasons and also like you guys
experienced this in St Louis you know
and I'm sure you do too I have places
and things that go when I'm in Chicago
and you'll bring somebody new and
they'll be like oh so you're like the
mayor of this and I go and I'm always
like no that guy's name is Brad Morris
yes I just know people here yes it's
truly who I bring up if anyone's ever
like who are you around in Chicago I'm
like you know Brad I'm sure it'll go
generations yeah yeah you can be well
after you left or well after you got
there I love Brad Morris yeah he's great
so we've been uh improvising together
since 2000 and multiple different teams
and Second City and everything and um
this podcast is it's this is a high
concept thing that you don't have to
know any of to listen to the podcast but
it's a prequel to a pilot we wrote of
these two idiot guys they're
um they have a travel show where they
just talk about travel it's a really bad
show this is in the pilot sure this is
in the future
um and the show gets canceled but the
FBI makes it keep going because the
sound guy is a serial killer they're
closing in on and do they know it and so
they're told that yeah that this these
are not gonna air but we have to keep
things normal till we finally have
enough evidence on this guy and they're
just idiots and they don't care about
the murdering they're like well we get
to make more of this show we're gonna
make it so good that it's undeniable so
these are podcasts of us with very funny
guests we'd love to have you guys next
season heartbeat man and uh and we
interview them about packing and the
best place to eat here there and then uh
it's always revealed that there's
another murder among our podcasts
the ticking Time Bomb is that there's a
serial killer in our midst yes and it's
the sound guy yeah that is so funny have
you ever had where like one of you
showed up late and the other one was
very worried that it was finally them
you weren't here for 10 minutes
I'm sorry oh my God I was panicking and
we we have the same uh recording
Engineers you guys Aaron and and we we
were like does Aaron get murdered at
some point if so we just need then Aaron
to always go by a different name but
yeah that's so funny because we still
need Aaron to do it right uh but play it
straight yeah yeah it's always like a
really sad day at the podcast and
there's a you know Chad sized hole and
we give a little quick eulogy and it's
always like we just found this out it
was just last night he was strangled in
his car right outside in the parking
right here the guests are always like
what is this part yeah
Comics like even though I don't know if
it's I would be as myself or as a
character but I can really speak to
travel and practice oh yeah yeah so you
can really talk about it while also
playing the game of the show and Luggage
the various types of luggage what's the
best type of luggage and what's the best
way to pack oh yeah they both get that
it's dumb and they have strong opinions
about yeah they're characters but
they're always like oh I just wanted to
talk about how weird the Denver Airport
is or something oh yeah yeah why is it
so far away what are they doing
underground one line it's yeah one line
one line
check and clear and I'm still waiting
for you it'll move faster than you think
what is worse security line at the
Denver airport or the check-in line for
Delta in Detroit
yeah terrible the worst yeah terrible
the worst yeah I'm there constantly so
the title of the podcast so people can
it's business trips business trips
didn't say that and uh yeah it's
everywhere you get podcasts that we do a
video version YouTube where early in
releasing them but check it out great I
love it please so when this gets
released you will have released a few
more and so it'll all be good I love
jump in jump in on that buttons trips I
love it Daniel you got a story let's
jump in
um oh
guys but I this somehow I put in a story
I already did what no dance okay I think
I have a backup you got it back oh my
God I don't care we don't care
um this happens sometimes I know so as
Dan's searching around what I wanted to
say about what I think is I think like
you can play the character of like a of
like a Midwestern specifically Michigan
Upper up Dad who is like flustered by
the minutia of the world I'm like there
is nobody to play it any better than
like if we were ever writing that
character I'd be like it's it's he can
do this yes overwhelmed by the basics of
Life yeah yeah it's super fun and
apparently people tell me I have an
accent they're like you can hear the
Michigan I'm like I can't hear that but
I love it you have it you have it in a
great way you've got it I have a
specific word that I don't I don't even
know how to say correct calendar
I've had people go calendar
calendar
to say correct you have to whisper it
yeah yeah calendar yeah yeah it's like
people who can't sing sing low volume
because you can't you go high it's out
yeah our buddy from Chicago or he's from
DC lives in Chicago he said that our
tell of our St Louis accent is when we
when we say we to do something I have to
do it I have to do it I have to do that
is it that is that never goes away for
me it's just calendar she has to I don't
I don't say hey I have to do it I don't
say Dad yeah a half hour 45 minutes
okay I found it I found one yeah we made
it back there send it by Brew pounder at
Brew pounder thank you just say I mean
could have been the guy from The Last
Story how many tins of Stella did he
found her also my favorite uh actor on
The Wire yeah this is a superpower this
is a fun little story I I can't say I
had it locked and loaded for a two but I
bet one
man steals pickle Patrol mobile what yes
pickle Patrol so is it a giant pickle
I'm assuming yeah it's like a hot dog
shape it's like the Wiener the wieners
or do they go around to pickleball
courts and get okay let's get it it's
just a green van it's just green to try
and make sure that people aren't
injuring other people doesn't Patrol
mean I'm against
I've been deputy deputies
on patrol isn't out there committing
crime no pickle Patrol would be like hey
you guys got pickles in this house no
pickles Street eating they just Dan as
there as they're driving
is that a pickle in your pocket or are
you just happy to see me well we're
gonna take you down sir pickle Patrol
step away step away from the dill Akron
Ohio okay has shown up recently and I've
once eaten by the way a full jar of mini
dill pickles in one sitting yeah I I go
crazy I've straight forked some dill
discs just real discs oh yeah hamburger
pickle yeah you guys ever go with the
they're thin but they're the they're the
like they went yeah like beers oh I know
what you're talking about it's like
instead of Julian like the Julian Julian
instead of going the fat way they went
the long way you two of those on a
burger yeah you're getting so much math
for me is with a pickle and my mouth is
watering as I'm saying this is sweet
dough
wait so you do love a sweet not a sweet
deal but a shirt kosher dill or new
pickle or garlic flavored all those I
love but recently I've had like it's
almost like a cucumber in sort of a
sweet sauce it's like from like a Thai
food thing that comes
what are we lacking That We crave
pickles because that's a big pregnancy
thing too we're right yeah yeah but if
we're we're all thinking about pickles
in this way like what is it salt
definitely salt and like there's like
vinegar the vinegar vinegar growing up
uh growing up and I would still do it to
this day I just haven't since I was a
kid the Princeton Flea Market Princeton
Wisconsin you can go listen to thanks
Diane if you want more of that content
but they
um you would just buy a full pickle
right and then you're just walking
around yeah that's a meal my kids at
Disneyland you can get pickles they
would go to Disneyland and get a pickle
like a pickle on a stick no it's just a
you like dancing ratifying a bite into
it yeah it's like biting it's like uh
you're Ozzy Osbourne biting off the head
of a bad word do I want a turkey leg for
that no I'm just gonna go in a pickle
Potbelly's has some huge pickles and
yeah your stomach if you picture the
size of your stomach it's just bigger
than the pickles right right you're like
how are we fitting all this content in
here what a pickle does to a Cubano
sandwich oh I agree dogs
a spear yeah spear okay
this made up for Greg it through the
garden nobody said that to me I've never
heard that before the bear okay
not that they're not seeing it down in
Bensonville okay Akron Ohio the Akron
pickle a company that specializes in
everything pickle okay I don't what is
that probably have your pickles what is
it I still think you should pickle
Patrol I scare people I know wants
people to know that if they saw their
prized pickle Patrol mobile driving
erratically on Tuesday afternoon it
wasn't them behind the wheel right we
can't it's like there's some damage
control like when someone gets a hold of
your Twitter my Twitter my picklemobile
got hacked they have a way that they
drive the pickle Patrol right that is
not being driven that way slow instead
it's all over to play making Lane
changes here and here pickle Patrol to
be a pickle version of an ice cream
truck but it's just Steely Dan music
instead of
I saw your pickle
you guys hear the song
My Favorite foreign movie uh Akron
Police confirm the company's delivery
truck was stolen and went for a wild
ride this isn't Cars the truck doesn't
have a feeling about it you know what I
mean this looks like the in from the
picture you showed me it looks like a VW
bus but the Wagoneer one which is like
the early 80s that's you know what I
think it is if you look at this
it's an ambulance oh yeah old ambulance
put that pickle on a stretcher butter is
vitals bringing out the dead get the
pickle paddles out according to police a
delivery driver for the company clear
was unloading items from the van when a
suspect jumped into the driver's seat
and took off with the door what do I
always say if you this has happened
before with police cars this has
happened on this show if you're going to
stop and be taking stuff out of the back
of your car turn off grab the keys yeah
what do you what is you're inviting
somebody to steal you know what happens
has happened a lot in larger cities you
are on the driver's side filling gas
you've just gotten out of your car you
think everything's chilling cool
somebody just walks up opens opens the
passenger side door grabs your wallet
whatever you have sitting there you
there's a car between you and them and
they already know what's happening and
you don't so right so at minimum you are
15 Paces behind before it even starts
what I'm hoping is that this story
reveals this suspect is
what if this was an inside job like 911
like 9 11. okay we don't need to get it
what happened
um he stole a pickle first time I'm
hearing about it police say before they
caught up with the suspect the delivery
driver of the pickle Patrol followed the
suspect with the help of a passerby so
they flagged down a car come on we're
going follow that pickle Patrol yeah you
guys in for this let's go yeah whoever
those people are yeah to be like yeah I
can do that instead of where I was going
right yeah I got the afternoon if you're
not in a knit Cage movie and you need to
steal a car immediately don't go with
something that's so easily tracked yeah
this is already this is wearing like a
hunter's vest might be the only green
car in Akron yeah yeah and they and they
wanted to Joyride apparently so that's
going to just be so you're drawing more
attention but it does make me feel like
Joyride this was just a dare yeah this
feels calculated yeah yeah they're not
dangerous they're just idiots police say
they caught up with the suspect oh I
just the person who was all like you
touched on I'm sorry we skipped but the
person who was like get in work will all
help we'll follow
that person is like this this is my
calling so he says we're gonna follow
things like you just picked the right
guy get the [__] in here get in here get
in here let's go follow that pickle man
you got it you're I'm the pursuit Patrol
stranger you ready let's go and the
stranger says I thought you'd never oh
exactly in my mind it was it was it was
hey man I saw I saw get in shotgun where
can someone steal that pickle mobile
he hands him a coffee and an aluminum
wrapped hand sandwich let's do this
he's like I'm ready to go let's do this
right now as they're driving he takes a
little bit of whiskey though like he's
like here let me top you off we got it
we got it and the other guy even though
they've never met before it turns his
left he's like you still doing that I
love these dragons like a thing that's
like suction cups to remove the
windshield so he can shoot through it oh
man how's his wife he's like it finally
happened where was that where was this
story I'm so happy for you honey I'm so
happy for you go get that pickle mobile
you go get it where was the storyline
when we were riding dumb people oh my
God okay police say before they caught
up to the suspect which was already like
don't blame us yeah this is before the
delivery driver of the pickle Patrol
filed associate with the help of
Professor by the driver told police that
the suspect took the stolen van to the
Village Thrift and e
and e Waterloo I don't know where he
went inside and stole several items yeah
yeah he's gonna pay if you're gonna
steal Bloomingdale's right I mean thrift
store yeah it's like I can get away this
is a whole crime of I can get away with
this and what did you need
to store that bad yeah lots of stuff
they're gonna they're gonna tell you
just take it anyway I I used to work at
Blockbuster and we would get robbed
every day no and they were like don't
don't chase the people and so I would
just make another question we can get
fill up their coats and just sort of jog
out the alarm would go off and I'd be
like ah yeah I guess
A League of Their Own yeah just let it
go this company will be around forever
so wait hang on one second
you're leaving
are you pick up troll nope just
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah dude make Mike
feel more comfortable right yeah right
you can smell it he can walk out of here
with this yeah payback [__] I don't
care okay so he runs into the to uh the
thrift store where he went inside and
see several stuff yeah he's caught up
with the pickle Patrol when they spot it
it makes it cute every time I say it
when they spotted the stolen vehicle
speeding along South Main Street police
tried to make a traffic stop but they
say the suspect refused and led officers
on a short Chase oh my God during the
pursuit the suspect ran several red
lights and committed other traffic
violations the chase ended when the
suspect drove back to East South Street
and then crashed into the back of a
building next to Hope Cafe oh my gosh it
feels so like he just ran into what he
needed hope Cafe to me sounds like a
1990s Indie movie or a WB show from 2003
to 2009 Cafe it's all a bunch of
teenagers at work there it's all dark an
older guy was kind of not open-minded
why are they giving us that detail what
it was next to you know
next to Hope Cafe because with everyone
you know hope Cafe yeah
we've had swords to start her out well
it happened again and we're like you're
a news organ
we're not like on a party line right
like but they didn't even use the like
hope as like a met like all hope was
lost for these guys when they crashed
into a whole game crashing down this
Thursday when the pickle Mobile Police
have identified the suspect as Lawrence
word of Akron which he walks into every
party
yes w-o-r word is born and blade these
are your sketch names
exactly I'm Lawrence word
wipe uh they're the present-day word in
Blaine word was taken into custody you
don't you custody after he ran into the
basement of the cafe okay so it did
matter yeah man again
building you go in the basement you guys
need pickles all right police said
clothing taken from the Village Thrift
Store was found inside the stolen
vehicle and the van was later returned
to the business owner the Akron pickle
that who that's who owns the pickle
patrolmobile don't even understand what
they do post it on Facebook we're Beyond
grateful that our staff the community
and our pickle truck were not harmed
today they add thank goodness it turned
out to not be a huge deal no no Lawrence
got himself into a bit of a pickle this
afternoon and we're grateful for
everyone uh who offered help and support
and to the Akron Police Department for
their quick reaction and ending the
situation safely I'll ask you guys just
for fun how old is Lawrence word who
wanted the pickle Patrol and it's needed
to go to the thrift store I believe the
company did a pun yeah you can't in the
middle of their stolen vehicles that
they didn't use it as the blow they was
just tucked in yeah you're right you
know what deal with it I'm gonna say 43
three years old okay deal or no deal I
may go 31.
43. what and you said
let that deal go down all right I'm a
Fool to do your pickle work oh yeah I'm
gonna say
48 48 mm-hmm Lawrence the pickle man
word yeah is
38 years old
wow I said 43. There You Go what'd you
say 31. okay all right there you go all
right I'd take us home Jay gonna take us
home and then uh
I think that's it I think that's okay
great there you go give us a little
taste of what we're gonna see on the
other side of this
um Maryland license plates are
advertising something inadvertently
there you go they don't sometimes they
don't know sometimes you don't know
what's on the back of your car and
people don't even pay attention anyway
we make mistakes at work all the time
sometimes no one notices in this case
everyone knows everyone knows that's it
dumb people tell Michael Brian's with us
we'll find out what Danny Van Kirk is
doing on the other side of the break
don't go anywhere
[Music]
we have a great sponsor so much fun I
want you to tell you about it you're
gonna love it I've been testing my
skills on prize picks this football
season it's the most exciting way to
play daily fantasy sports if you have
the skills you can turn ten dollars into
250 with just a few Taps prize picks
offers weekly promotions that can lead
to Big payouts like taco Tuesday but I
mean can you guess which day of the week
uh that's Tuesday stuff like this yeah
uh price picks discount select player
projections up to 25 to provide even
more value so you get a little bit of a
little bit of fun on the juice yeah
price picks now offers Apple pay for
quick and easy deposits into your
account this football season love of
deposit with prize picks so I made I'm
making a couple of prize picks this week
I'll tell you mine what I decided to do
that's when this when when this as of
when we're recording as of when we're
recording this just to show you some of
what the prize picks they do how fun it
is Rock Purdy they have Brock Purdy
quarterback for the San Francisco 49ers
undefeated uh said will he go over or he
will he achieve 229.5 yards is that what
he's going to get passing I believe he
will yeah based on just what he did I'm
taking the over on that I think he's
gonna hit that weapons he's got three
weapons so uh how about this if you want
to get and they they get get right down
to it Zach Wilson backup quarterback for
the Jets now not anymore well I know but
you never know wait what is it what's
the 167.5 so I if he plays yeah he's the
starter now because you know they're
gonna have to pass the law it's going to
be a shoot you absolutely do so like
Garrett Wilson is going to be okay he
just got the wind knocked out of him so
that to me is an easy one I'd maybe say
yes he's gonna he's I mean maybe you're
a WNBA fan you say Brianna Stewart 34.5
points in the game she's one of the
greatest players of all time I'll take
that bet you're taking it right now yeah
I am it's like all these Sports and all
these things it's so much fun it's so
easy apple pay makes it easy and it
gives you a chance and we got a deal
going right now that's right go to
prizefix.com TPT use the code DPT for a
first deposit match up to a hundred
dollars that's prizepix.com DPT use the
code DPT for a first deposit match up to
100 promo code all lower case prize
picks daily fantasy sports made easy
foreign
hey guys welcome back to the show I hope
you're doing well and you made it
through the break okay Daniel where can
people catch you and see your special
tape I'm very excited for Jason's Story
because I love Municipal dumbness yes uh
but so I want to tell everybody quickly
go to
danielvankirk.com if this is the
beginning of November we're looking at
Milwaukee Lincoln Cedar Rapids uh
Indianapolis Louisville Rochelle two
shows first Show's already sold out
second one might be about this probably
about a quick a quick late night show
that is in Rochelle Illinois go to
danielvanger.com and then on Saturday
probably tickets are only left for The
Late Show but go and look I'm at the
Lincoln Lodge filming my first ever
special it's also my recording for my
second album It's rose gold I hope all
of you are there some of you familiar
townies and and people who are pen pals
you you hopefully know the deal I can
get some of you into the after party and
anybody who comes to any show this is
the most fun any you townies I love you
all bring dumb headlines I started a
show out by talking to you about them
and the last thing I'll say quickly
there's a lot of stuff we are not
allowed to promote these days so be on
the lookout for things we can't promote
yeah there you go that's it I love it
mark your calendar right calendar
baby make a wish shoot it there yeah so
it's all at Daniel Van Kirk dead I love
it all right so uh here we go Maryland
license by Professor demerita Oh I
thought you were going to say and one at
Ann McCarthy and McCartney is Anne new
I'm not sure thank you Anne uh Maryland
life Maryland license plates now
inadvertently advertising Filipino
online casino this is great what
Filipino online casino they have ads are
do all license plates have ads so let me
I feel like I've seen ones that say
dmv.gov at the bottom I don't know why
but so they probably did one that was a
different this to me sounds like the
beginning of a musical it's an online
casino it's Filipino a Filipino online
casino uh okay
um we'll get into how many Maryland
drivers who told you about it cousin
Gino so I guess they did calm instead of
gov Janet Reno uh Maryland drivers
Rick Pitino Maryland drivers with
slicing in the restaurant you can have
sex on the table 15 seconds with Rick
Pitino and some Vino that's Bill little
Vino I was gonna say all right sorry uh
Maryland drivers was license plates
designed to commemorate the war of 1812.
nice are now inadvertently advertising a
website for an online casino based in
the Philippines there you go they're
supporting Manny Pacquiao by mistake in
2012 to celebrate the 200th anniversary
of the War of 1812 Maryland redesigned
its standard license plate to read
Maryland war of 1812. how is that
promoting a Filipino online casino it's
a little more up at the border no oh it
was down there all right lice
yeah I thought it was us against Canada
but yeah I'm gonna take you and me for
the win but Maryland just wanted to get
in on the action because they probably
sent a lot of people up there they were
around back then just a couple people
yeah we lost a lot of good people up
there yeah uh at the board we lost a lot
of good people at that Filipino Casino
probably have online your uncles to come
to addiction down at that Filipino
Casino online
uh so anyway uh the license plates which
were the default between 2012 and 2016
have the URL
www.star
spangled200.org printed at the bottom
Star Spangled so this casino is going to
be called The Star-Spangled Casino so
sometimes so if you're a Filipino Casino
Pro tip make sure that the thing is like
something I'm jingoistically American
nothing says Filipino Casino more than
anything so sometime within the last
year
www.starspangled200.org stop telling
people about how marylander Francis
Scott
to write the national anthem the
Star-Spangled Banger Banner after
watching British ships bombard Fort
McHenry in Baltimore during the War of
1812 and started in Stand instead
redirecting to a site called
globeinternational dot info in which a
blinking bikini-clad woman advertises
Philippines best betting site 200
received 250. Star Spangled Banger
sounds like that could be the issues
Baltimore what the hell is this come on
Juan askout horn
the issue was that's really good was
spotted by a redditor who said uh I've I
was never a fan of having a plate
celebrating the war of 1812. all right
we care about your your opinion about
the old ones
look I'm not a big government guy I
thought you said late and I'm like this
person just hates commemorative plates
listen I am not a big fan of drones
looking into your kitchen like we asked
you about it it's so off topic I don't
like peeing sitting down but I'll do it
if I have to what was the question all
right that's that's by the way my dad's
big thing is he said if I ever see a
drone come and just hang out outside my
bedroom window I'm gonna shoot that
thing down I'm gonna that's like that's
never gonna happen yeah is this
something that you're concerned about on
the rag there's a pet peeve I didn't
have 30 years ago we can make this
happen
see how serious he is about shooting
that thing and then we'll get all all of
our friends to bet how long before your
money where your mouth is Dad that's
what are their drone outside
it's May 11th he's Ray Liotta it's just
his own Henry Hill Day
uh someone wanted to watch me sleep
I was never a fan of having played
celebrating War of 1812 but I'm even
more upset now that I and tons of other
melners are driving advertisements for
international online gambling are you
really upset about it I hate to be Bill
Maher but are you really that it's a
mistake is it worth getting that okay
basically doing Kyle Dunnigan only thing
worse would have been the original plan
about the 1812. yeah he hated that play
but like I didn't like the you can think
it's funny you can think it's odd and
weird you can point it out and be like
God the world's dumb you can't be mad
about this and I'm also mad about
Stonewall Jackson and if you'll sit down
I'll tell them I'll tell you everything
domain registration information shows
that star spangled200.org has been
re-registered and transferred a handful
of times within the last few years it's
not exactly clear when it stopped being
a website about American history so
people don't change their license plates
what's the history about this American
history
the internet archive shows that as
recently as December 2022 the website
explained that the young United States
was embroiled in the War of 1812 at
Chesapeake Bay Region felt the brunt of
it a second we're learning a snapshot
from today however explains that
extremely lenient laws governing gaming
in the Philippines this is the result of
a growing popularity of gambling among
tourists in the enormous Casino Resorts
that have been built a spokesperson for
the Maryland Department of
Transportation Motor Vehicle
Administration told motherboard that
there are currently how many active War
of 1812 licenses so how many mistakes
are out here out there just going to
make those people turn them in so I
don't know I don't know this is what we
have to find out I'm going to guess
there's 15 000 of them out there 50 000
mistakes driving around and found the
casino I'm like you can have this
website it's going to cost you yeah yeah
they bought it to Route it red or black
just right you buy it and then it routes
I like that they're more lenient about
their gambling I wonder what that means
yeah yeah they're just so long extremely
you can stand next to the dealer
you can double or nothing anything yeah
anytime two trips to the buffet you're
allowed to bet a pillow
just slap down on the table what happens
if I want to split this hand
I'll get another one how many how many
cards you think are out there driving
with this bad website I'm gonna go
higher yeah uh 15
0001. oh you so damn yeah for sure I
think it's like 80 000.
get your answers in because it was
probably a long time before it's four
years of it oh where they're cranking
them out from 2012 to 2016 cranking yeah
no no no I'll stick but I I I oh I'm
gonna adjust to 210 000. oh then I'm
adjusting to 84 000. I'll stay fifteen
thousand one get your answers in now my
one makes no sense there are currently
000.
oh that's a million cars driving around
because this was the this was the
standardization from 2012 to 2016
cleaning is the the gal and the bikini
oh yeah she's getting so much exposure
yeah who's losing the guy more ways than
one day the guy in the license plate
office at the DMV who's like you know we
should start doing like you know tie-ins
on each of these license plates so I
don't know about other states I think
Illinois maybe has two but it just shows
nine different like California it just
shows how little they vet this stuff
they just don't vet it at all yeah the
uh website print on the plates is is not
owned by the Motor Vehicle
Administration in case anyone right who
plays design and content originated from
the War of 1812 Bicentennial commission
created in 2007 Star Spangled 200
Incorporated is the non-profit entity
affiliated with the commission that led
the efforts to raise funds for
Bicentennial projects and events they
said the MVA does not endorse the views
or content on current website using that
our URL and is working with the agencies
I to identify options to resolve the
current issue you can either recall the
plates or fix the website fix that is
your choice I'm saying they're like
we'll let you fix this it's going to
cost you it would have been great if
they they were like and they actually
like the casino now they have to come
out and say like we don't endorse we
don't love it so what if they change it
to someone else is going to buy that
website and change it to like porn only
fans yeah the War of 1812 or something
like that and unless the casino goes
under all you have to do is do what they
should and just auto pay it just like
it's a website where like an old woman's
like you want to see a musket disappear
no no I do not only fans of the war of
1812. uh you better save that idea I
will there you go pretty good uh that's
it uh so don't be short-sighted when you
put a website up on Alexis bet your
stuff yeah go to the website once yeah
go find it okay all right the uh the
name of the podcast is called business
trips with Mike O'Brien and our buddy
Brad Morris check it out it's going to
be your new favorite podcast subscribe
leave comments enjoy it love it support
all of us when we're on the road and see
us this is the way to do it right now
while we're in the midst of two strikes
supporting us live in LA or out on the
road is the way to do it we love you
guys and oh [__] we gotta get back to
work bye
town
[Music]